power Cuts have been a problem for
decades in Lebanon because of a
dysfunctional energy sector and now a
nearly bankrupt State struggles to
afford fuel forcing many to rely on
private generators
for those who can install solar power
it's 10 times cheaper it's also cheaper
than State electricity
energy conservationists say the game
changer Was the removal of subsidies on
conventional power sources after or
following the economic crisis in 2019
the demand on electricity decreased and
the practically according to Aussie lcec
estimations today we believe that the
demand on electricity is around 1700
megawatts so practically the existing
power plants together with the existing
solar installations could solve the
legalistic crisis of LeBron but first
the state needs to ensure a minimum
supply of power to allow solar
installations to connect to the National
Grid conventional power plants are a
base load and they should remain in the
energy mix of the country it's essential
to have conventional power plant solar
panels aren't enough to keep the lights
on
Europe I installed solar panels but I
couldn't get rid of my generator because
I need 24 hours of power to preserve the
meat
30 of the country's electricity Supply
now comes from renewable sources
Lebanon has exceeded its 1000 megawatt
ceiling for solar installations that
means the country has met its 2030
Target to reduce emissions
that was not the result of a plan to
tackle global warming it was a reaction
to the economy's collapse but still one
in five households can't afford power
one ampere cost is 30 to 35 so I live
without electricity
an estimated 80 000 households have gone
green that's a fraction of the 1.5
million who need the government to do
its part